The sister of one of the victims in what's
likely the most high-profile murder case
of all time is slamming true-crime shows for
not doing enough to include the perspectives
of victims' families. She particularly
focused on one popular, recent example.
Netflix's "Dahmer – Monster: The Jeffrey Dahmer
Story" has generated a lot of controversy,
with ethical concerns over its depiction
of events, details from the show's set,
and the showrunners reportedly not consulting
the families of Dahmer's victims. Yet the
series also smashed a Netflix record by
becoming the streamer's biggest debut ever.
Dramatizations of real-life
crimes really have to walk a
fine line. While entirely fictional crime series,
like "Ozark" and "Good Girls," can get away with
some comic relief and outlandish storylines,
true crime has a responsibility to depict events
at least fairly close to how they really happened.
According to Kim Goldman, "Monster" did not hit
that target. She is the sister of Ron Goldman,
the man who was killed alongside Nicole Brown
Simpson in 1994. O.J. Simpson was tried and
acquitted for both murders. Kim is now a writer
who also works with nonprofit organizations on
a variety of causes. As the sister of a
high-profile murder victim, she did not
mince words in her criticism of "Monster" in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly. Goldman said,
"Some article said Netflix is not
required to notify the families.
And it bugged me! How s---ty is
that, that it doesn't even dawn on
you from just a human space that you
would give someone a courtesy call?"
Goldman added that when she and her family heard
about the FX series "The People v. O. J. Simpson:
American Crime Story," they reached
out to ask what they could learn.
"We asked if we could see an advanced
copy — we were told no. [...] I said,
'Well, that's unfortunate.' It kind
of works against you. If you were to
at least share it with me, then
I would be able to say, 'Hey,
they shared it with me, and this is what
I feel about it.' Missed opportunity."
"The People v. O.J. Simpson" and "Monster" both
had the same executive producer, Ryan Murphy.
"You know, there's so many places that they took
creative liberties, and a part of me is thinking,
you know, 'Why do we need this show?' We had it
on television, gavel-to-gavel, for 10 months."
Goldman has raised the possibility of a law
requiring filmmakers to consult with families.
She speculated as to the reasons why creative
teams would not contact families, saying,
"I would imagine [it's] because of the
pushback that a production company or a
network would receive if a family got wind [of
a project] and wanted some kind of involvement."
Goldman's issue with true crime shows and films
not consulting families isn't just about a lack
of courtesy. Viewers have the expectation
that what they're viewing is a fictionalized,
but still largely accurate account of
events. But a well-rounded account of
what happened would be difficult to portray
without consulting the families of victims.
Goldman compared the idea of a true-crime
show that doesn't consult those families
to an "unauthorized" biography written without
the subject's permission or knowledge. She said,
"When or if I choose to read that book, now
I know the lens with which to view it. I feel
like that could be applied to these types of
shows, and then people can decide whether to
watch it... I'm not trying to stop people from
[watching], but just maybe to have a different
sensitivity as you consume the show that it
wasn't at the pleasure of the victim's family."
Goldman also shared that she asked Jeffrey Toobin,
the author of the book that "Monster" was based
on, about why family members of Dahmer's
victims were not consulted. She recalled:
"He said, 'Well, it wasn't victim-focused.'
And I'm like, 'Well, that's the problem.'"
Goldman added,
"I think it's changed a little bit over the
last couple of years, but most of the shows
are from the criminal's perspective, from the
law enforcement perspective, from the legal
perspective. Very seldom do you often see it from
a victim's perspective. It paints a picture that
victims and survivors are in the background,
you know, in a fetal position on the floor."
She said the experience of the
victims is just as important as
those of the criminals and
the police. Goldman said:
"It's irresponsible to not in some way
include the families so that you can
understand what they're experiencing and to
give a little bit more power back to them."